[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle aurélien et je suis
accro aux smartphones je suis sûr que
vous l'êtes vous aussi je vous donnais
pour sa 8 preuve que vous êtes accro à
votre smartphone que vous avez du mal à
vous en passer et que vos smartphones
occupent beaucoup trop de place dans
votre vie quotidienne pour ça j'ai plein
de petits éléments plein de choses sur
lesquelles je travaille et je consomme
pour tenir tout au long de la vidéo
si vous vous reconnaissez dans ce que je
vous décris dans les huit points que
vous citez et dites moi tout de suite au
début de la vidéo est ce que vous pensez
être accro à votre smartphone oui ou
alors absolument pas du tout avant toute
chose que je vous invite à faire c'est à
vous abonner parce que je parle bien
évidemment de smartphones de nouveaux
produits là je vous parle du fait d'être
accro smartphones mais moi j'adore les
smartphones je suis un très gros
utilisateurs de smartphones et
personnellement je les adore je les aime
et c'est pour ça que j'ai choisi d'en
faire mon métier
mais comme dans toute chose il y a des
travers il faut faire attention et il
faut se protéger pour ne pas avoir à
subir nos objets technologiques dont je
vous invite à cliquer sur le petit
bouton rouge que vous avez là actionner
la cloche comme ça vous saurez tout sur
l'actu smartphones et sur les bons
usages à quoi ça c'est le premier point
le deuxième point je sais pas si vous le
savez si vous l'avez vu sur les réseaux
sociaux
j'ai lancé un podcast le tout premier
podcast qui s'appelle fréquence gros
docteur joly parle comme la dvi damman
de teck de nos usages de ce qui va ce
qui va pas de produits plein de choses
et le tout premier podcast qui justement
vient résonnait que cette vidéo et
sommes-nous accro à nos smartphones quel
plaisir je ne vous le cache pas c'est le
premier podcast le premier podcast de
monsieur gros monsieur greu arrive dans
vos oreilles après avoir vu sur youtube
vous me voyez donc vous m'avez
directement dans vos oreilles avec un
nouveau podcast qui s'appelle fréquence
bruel c'est un podcast qui durent
quarante et quelques minutes dans lequel
il ya invité ses korben qui a sorti ce
livre qui est très cool
libérez vous de votre smartphone aux
éditions jets réseau on en reparle à la
fin de la vidéo parce que ça c'est un
outil qui peut être vraiment très
intéressant pour vous aider en tout cas
à vous libérer votre addiction aux
smartphones on va donc rentrer tout de
suite dans le vif du sujet je vous
donnais 8 points que vous permettront de
savoir si oui ou non vous êtes accros au
smart phone ce qu'on trouve formidable
évidemment ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire regardez j'ai rajouté une
caméra regardez-la coup voilà on
n'arrête pas le progrès chez monsieur
breda c'est pratique c'est bien le tout
premier point et je sais pas si ça vous
arrive souvent c'est le besoin
impérieux de savoir ce qui se passe
alors que vous êtes je sais pas à moi
dans la rue en cours au travail
n'importe où ou même le soir chez vous
dans le lit vous avez besoin de savoir
ce qui se passe si vous avez peur de
manquer une information alors qu'est ce
qu'on fait à ce moment-là on ouvre son
smartphone on va sur les différents
réseaux sociaux que ce soit instagram
facebook youtube et compagnie et on
vient regarder un petit peu ce qu'on
aurait loupé ce que nos amis auraient
mis et qu'on ne connaît pas on peut
aller plus loin avec les sites
d'information on trouve nos propres
centres d'intérêt et on est toujours en
train de se connecter par peur d'avoir
manqué une information ça c'est pas
terrible c'est une mauvaise habitude et
on est très nombreux à l'avoir
le deuxième point je n'ai remarqué moi
et c'est un truc qui me fait extrêmement
bizarre c'est le fait de prendre son
smartphone machinalement par exemple
vous marchez dans la rue moi ça
m'arrivait ya pas longtemps je marche
dans la rue je prends mon smartphone je
le délai rouille et une feuille de route
je me dis mais pourquoi est ce que j'ai
fait ça je suis perdu je n'ai pas besoin
de le consulter à ce moment là en train
de marcher ça peut même être stupide de
marché dans l'année sans téléphone sans
regarder ce qui a devant soi et autour
de soi et sans prendre conscience des
fois du monde qui nous entoure et c'est
là que j'ai eu une prise de conscience
je suis en train d'allumer mon
smartphone alors que je n'en ai
absolument pas le besoin au la lune plus
par réflexe que pour un usage
instantanée ou pour un réel besoin
le troisième point et on est vraiment
dans les mécanismes de la dépendance
c'est ce qu'on appellera la libération
de la dopamine alors on va pas rentrer
dans une notion d' addict aux alors de
médecine mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que la dopamine c'est l'hormone du
plaisir c'est l'hormone de la récompense
dès lors que vous avez quelque chose qui
vous plaît vous avez une récompense
eh bien vous avez une libération de
dopamine qui vient mettre votre cerveau
dans un état pas d'euphorie mais de
plaisir instantané
ça dure pas très longtemps c'est quelque
chose qu'on ressent notamment lorsqu on
va sur les réseaux sociaux qu'on tombe
sur un article qui nous plaît ça c'est
quelque chose qui a été à démontrer et
dénoncé par des personnes qui
travaillent est justement dans ces
réseaux sociaux et qui disait que les
réseaux travail en ce sens là qui
travaillent à vous rendre accro de par
le fait d'avoir un feed infinie de par
le fait de toujours avoir quelque chose
qu'on peut regarder ça ne s'arrête
strictement jamais eh bien on est
rapidement accro et quand répondre
quelque chose qui nous plaît on a une
libération dopamine et sans même qu'on
le sache lorsqu'on a un petit coup de
mou une baisse de régime notre cerveau
va chercher à libérer de la dopamine et
à nous fournir du plaisir ce qui va
entraîner un effet pervers par derrière
et ça je vous en parle dans le podcast
donc une fois de plus vital et le
l'écouté je vous ai mis les liens bien
évidemment dans la description ça va
engendrer des tensions deux mal être de
par la dépendance ça peut aller du petit
coup de blues passager à la dépression
ça ça dépend bien évidemment
tant chacun est le quatrième point je
suis sûr qu'on est très nombreux à le
faire soyez vraiment transparent soyons
honnêtes écoutez ça ils marquent les
mois après en vain commentaires on est
très nombreux très nombreux et très
nombreuses à regarder notre smartphone
avant de vous coucher
que ce soit la dernière chose qu'on
regarde au moment de se coucher au tollé
dans les lits on navigue on le pose et
on dort ça peut durer un certain temps
et bien souvent ça marche de père c'est
la première chose que vous allez
regarder le matin quand vous allez vous
réveiller alors si elle réveille bien
évidemment c'est un type obligatoire
mais souvent ce qu'on fait et moi ça
m'arrive je sais pas si ça vous arrive à
vous mais surpris que ça vous arrive pas
on allume son smartphone et
immédiatement on va se connecter sur les
réseaux sociaux on va regarder ses
e-mails l'on va aller sur instagram
on va aller sur twitter on va aller sur
facebook on va regarder ce qui se passe
toujours dans l'année l'idée de se dire
j'ai peut-être loupé un truc ça peut
être important je vais aller voir sans
même en avoir réellement conscience dit
moi maintenant vous c'est ce que vous
faites
le soir vous regardez votre smartphone
le matin vous vous réveillez vous le
regardez même très rapidement ouvert
vous vous levez vous allez aux toilettes
vous l'allumez vous le regardez marqué
le mois en bas en commentaire et je
pense qu'on va être très nombreux et
très nombreux et dans ce cas là le
cinquième point qui nous permet de
savoir si on est dépendant sur
smartphone c'est de regarder son temps
d'écran le temps que vous passez dans
votre smartphone c'est quelque chose
qu'on trouve dans tous les smartphones
vous retrouver dans tous les os ce soit
à ios que ce soit android vous avez vos
temps d'écran qui apparaissent sur ios
institut d'antan d'écran et là je vois
ma moyenne quotidienne tu vois si je
monte si je baise je vois où j'en suis
je peux voir les applications que j'ai
consulté le plus et voir à quoi je suis
accro et je pense que les réseaux
sociaux voient quelque chose qui vont
ressortir plus plus plus plus plus plus
en tout cas ça peut vous permettre de
prendre conscience que vous êtes trop
sur votre smartphone le sixième point
c'est la peur de sortir sans votre
smartphone je sais pas si ça vous le
fais moi ça m'est arrivé plusieurs fois
de partir aller acheter du pain une
bêtise à chercher mon fils à l'école
j'ai pas mon smartphone dell genre
france j'ai l'impression d'avoir quelque
chose d'essentiel qui me manquent et que
je n'ai pas sur moi à ce moment là
faites le test
posez votre smartphone est parti faire
des courses pour une heure pour deux
heures
il ya toute une mécanique qui va vous
creed station un peu bizarre je peux
dire que ce soit du mal être mais très
bizarre la sensation d'avoir oublie
quelque chose d'important comme si vous
allez faire vos courses et que vous avez
oublié votre argent ce qui marche pas à
quoi briller et après on va trouver
toutes les bonnes raisons pour légitimer
le fait d'avoir son smartphone avec soin
le fait d'avoir besoin d'un gps pour se
repérer dans une boutique connaître les
horaires d'ouverture d'une boutique
le fait de pouvoir rejoindre un ami si
besoin le fait de pouvoir répondre à un
message important le fait de risquer une
fois de plus de manquer quelque chose je
peux vous assurer que si vous avez
vous passer de votre smartphone lorsque
vous sortez ces potentats prouver que
vous n'êtes pas accro mais dans la
plupart des cas je suis sûr qu'on aura
du mal à sortir sans son smartphone sans
que ça nous créé une sensation de mal
être septième point ce sont les usages
inopportun je vous explique ça par
exemple vous êtes avec des amis à table
et va arriver un moment où vous dites
maintien je vais jeter un petit coup
d'oeil pendant le repas vous prenez
votre smartphone ils vont regarder ce
qui se passe
il ya quelques années on aurait dit mais
qu'est ce que tu fais ça marche pas
quand tu fais ça on est ensemble
aujourd'hui on est très nombreux et très
nombreux à le faire et ça rentre un peu
dans les codes un peu standard c'est
plus gênant c'est plus d'écho n'en ont
pas tout le temps mais de prendre
smartphones et de regarder si on a un
message même ça vous le prenez vous
regardez si vous avez un message alors
que vous êtes avec vos amis à table
c'est quand même relativement déconnant
et pourtant on est très nombreux et très
nombreuses à le faire alors je vous
parle du fait d'être à table vous êtes
en cours et un truc est aussi
extrêmement révélateur c'est le fait
d'utiliser plusieurs écrans en même
temps par exemple vous regardez un film
le soir détendu tranquillement sur votre
tablette votre télé ce que vous voulez
peu importe
sauf sur vos smartphones et à ce moment
là vous utilisez votre smartphone vous
continuer à regarder ce qui se passe sur
les réseaux vous consulter des magazines
en ligne vous surfez alors que vous êtes
déjà occupa tu as quelque chose s'attend
vraiment à prouver qu'une fois de plus
votre smartphone vous appelle vous
n'êtes pas assez stimulée par votre film
pour le passé du temps dessus il ya un
petit temps borg une baisse de régime
eh bien vous prenez votre smartphone
vous consultez pourquoi parce que vous
avez besoin d'un stimuler parce que vous
avez besoin d'avoir des charges de
dopamine et voyez une fois de plus c'est
très bizarre c'est très bizarre parce
qu'on vit on regarde un film on n'a pas
besoin de faire ça et pourtant on fait
ça déconne et le huitième point j'en ai
parlé dans le podcast assez korben qui
m'a fait remarquer effectivement mais
sur du concret ça m'était déjà arrivé
c'est la vibration fantôme on est
souvent nos smartphones dans notre poche
et lorsqu'on reçoit un message il vibre
est ce que ça vous est déjà arrivé quand
une fois plus pour me dire en bas en
commentaire alors que vous n'aviez pas
votre smartphone dans votre poche vous
n'avez rien à votre poche vous sentez
une petite vibration comme si vos
smartphones vibrer vous poser la main
sur votre poche et bien évidemment le
smartphone ne s'y trouve pas et c'est
assez déstabilisant
c'est une fois de plus votre cerveau qui
vous trompe et qu'en bas nous explique
très bien justement dans le podcast
c'est votre cerveau qui vous trompez qui
vous appelle à l'utilisation de votre
smartphone pour avoir son petit chute de
dopamine
si vous vous reconnaissez dans un de ces
huit à avoir dans plusieurs de ses 8 4
je vous le dis vous êtes accro à votre
smartphone alors rassurez vous c'est pas
une fatalité
moi ce que je regrette c'est de bien
consulter le livre de korben libérez
vous de votre smartphone qui donne
pleins de conseils intéressants alors
j'ai pas vous le feriez tout de suite
mais voyez
optez le mode avion il pas mal de choses
lors éveil changer de forfait est enfin
là ya pas mal de choses à l'intérieur
c'est très intéressant on a eu une
discussion d'à peu près une demi heure
dans le podcast vous aviez bien
évidemment d'une à venir le découvrir de
vous abonner au podcast et 3 à l'écouté
parce que c'est une mine d'informations
c'est très intéressant sa part de la
prise de conscience de l'addiction aux
smartphones à toutes les solutions est
une fois de plus si ce bouquin vous
intéresse vous a mis un lien en bas dans
la description a vous de me dire vous
maintenant est-ce que vous pensez que
vous êtes accro à votre smartphone est
ce que vous avez envie de changer les
choses est ce que ça vous pourrit la vie
est-ce que vous avez déjà fait le pas de
vous libérer de votre smartphone
et est-ce que vous en êtes satisfait est
ce que vous aviez replonger marquera
tout ça on va en commentaire sans si je
donne rendez vous extrêmement rapidement
pour continuer à parler tech je vais
vous reparler de smartphones j'ai plein
d'actus ya plein de nouveaux smartphones
attester que ce soit de côté de chez au
pot du côté de chez sony ya des produits
qui vont arriver aussi du côté de chez
xiaomi à des mondes connectés ya des
tablettes c'est de la télé
la très belle télé wicca concept est
très très prochainement donc
abonnez-vous si ce n'est pas déjà le cas
sur ce genre à savoir beaucoup d'amour
je donne rendez vous extrêmement
rapidement pour continuer à parler tech
a très vite les épisodes chacun
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]